مصيره ام مصير شعبه يتداخل المسلك فبن
يامين نتنياهو يقود الحرب وهو الملام على
الطوفان الذي
اوجدها الحقيقه ان متاعب اطول رؤساء
الوزراء حكما في اسرائيل لم تبدا مع هجوم
المقاومه المباغت غير المسبوق وليست هذه
اول مره تثار فيها مساله نهايه مس نتنياهو
السياسيه الطويله من بوابه انتخابات العام
الماضي التشريعيه عاد الملك بي بي كما
يلقب الى السلطه مسنودا بتحالفه مع اقصى
اليمين وتشكيلات
متطرفه فماذا حدث حتى صار موقع نتنياهو
القيادي يثير احتجاجات شرائح من قاعدته
الانتخابيه كانت تدعمه في وجه المتظاهرين
الرافضين اصلاحاته القضائيه المثيره للجدل
نتنياهو الملاحق قضائيا في ثلاث قضايا
فساد كان في حل من مازق جديد طالما تباه
بانه حقق الامن والرخاء لاسرائيل
وذاك مقتله الذي اصابته المقاومه
الفلسطينيه قد يحتاج الشارع الاسرائيلي في
الظرف الراهن الى سلطه حازمه توقع ما توصف
بعمليه الانتقام من حماس لكن ليسوا قله في
اسرائيل من يرون ان نتنياهو ليس الانسب
للمهمه فالاخ فاق الامني والاستخباري
والعسكري تم في عهد حكومته
الائتلافيه تلك التي لم تستقل ولم تقل بل
مددت لنفسها في شكل حكومه طوارئ موسعه تضم
جزءا من المعارضه قد يفسر ذلك ما تبينه
استطلاعات الراي في اسرائيل من تراجع كبير
لشعبيهما
بحزبه فماذا لو جرت انتخابات الكنيست الان
يخلص استطلاع اجرته صحيفه معريف الى ان
حصه حزب نتنياهو الليكود ستتراجع ساعتها
الى 19 مقعدا فيما شعبيه خصمه السياسي
بيني جانس سترتفع مع حصول حزبه الوحده
الوطنيه على 41 مقعدا يعتبر
48% من المستطلع ارائهم ان جانس هو الانسب
لتولي منصب رئيس الحكومه مقابل
29% يتمسكون بنتنياهو رئيسا
للوزراء اه بدايه السقوط كما يتنبا بذلك
خبراء في السياسه
الاسرائيليه قد لا تتضح معالم مستقبل
نتنياهو السياسي حتى تنتهي المواجهه
الراهنه مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اذا استمر في منصبه حتى تلك
اللحظه فهل سيتجنب
المسائله ترى وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان
لجنه تحقيق حكوميه قد تخلص بعد الحرب الى
انه يتحمل المسؤوليه عن سقوط قتلى في
هجمات المقاومه لكنها تستدرك بان ذلك لن
يكون ملزما قانونا لنتنياهو
وحده ضغط الراي العام سيبلغ به مستوى لن
يترك له خيارات كثيره na oj